As an alternative formulation of the same story, we could have a table. And
typically the table will have three columns. One column is the agent or
actor involved in that particular step of the story, and
this is going to be Foster. And it's going to be the Amazon web server.
The second column indicates the action that's taking place.
This might be the user action it might be the system response and
the third column, contains information about any object, that, is conveyed,
in that particular step. So it might be for example credit card information.
Same information in the unstructured version and
the tabular version. They’re both examples of use cases, and
they would represent the content of one of the ovals used in this diagram.